this is dr. viktor frankl professor of
psychiatry and neurology at the
University of Vienna on top of that
president of the Austrian Medical
Society for psychics
on top of that he's the author of some
of the widely read books in our time
among them from death camp to
existentialism the doctor in the soul
and his newest book man's search for
meaning dr. Frankel from Vienna is here
to discuss with us tonight some of the
crucial questions which haunt all of us
regarding modern man his troubles his
anxieties and his hope for the future
when said that there are three
revolutions that have come out of Vienna
Adler would his will to power
Freud with his search for pleasure and
now dr. Frankel who speaks to a modern
man wherever he is about the world
meaning once I was it consulted by an
old general practitioner of the outer
part of Vienna and he told me dr. panky
I came to see you because of the severe
depression which which I'm suffering
throughout the last two years since my
wife died and I can't get over I can't
get rid of this depression it's nonsense
to approach me doctor because any
prescription I could make myself but
nevertheless I the feeling I should
speak to you talk with you
then there was a pause and he asked me
what what should I do and then they give
him any advice I didn't tell him
anything but I just asked him a question
I asked this old dr. tehrani doctor what
would
if you had died first and your wife
would have had to survive at the
survivor step on it
oh how this would have been terrible how
she had suffered that when I rethought
it well this suffering doctor your wife
has been spared this suffering and it
was you who could spare her this
Authority but now it is rain who has to
pay for it you are built for it by the
fact that now you have two more you have
to suffer you have to survive her this
man looks me up and then his to death
gave me his hand and silently left my
office
he found conservation this reversal of
attitude taught a state which could no
longer be changed they could not revive
his right you understand right but I
could change his attitude suddenly he
saw meaning the meaning of a sacrifice
at the same moment there was no
discretion any longer he could overcome
this depression it was it remained still
chuckling but it was suffering for the
sake of somebody so you're saying the
events of life apart for meanings are
useless man cannot be healthy without
meaning without meaning beckoning things
he he could not even be remain alive you
know who has passes Albert Einstein
returned no psychiatrist and now I think
psychiatry should be reminded of this
primary motivational for a man that
managed primarily and basically reaching
out for meaning and man must be prepared
to in do
the tension between the meanings which
is in wait for him and the beings the
actual being the actual state of affairs
this is the gap between between between
what he is and what he should become
what he ought to be this gas must be
imbued and so I would certainly tell him
to remind me that the homeostasis
principle is prevalent prevalent and
dominating presence a sexuality that man
is a being we just want to satisfy the
drive to gratify his desire to fulfill
the need to to follow his wife this I
believe is not the actor to me I think
that man is no being in steady quest for
maintaining or restoring his inner equal
enjoyment for this perfect to this for
this purpose satisfying needs and drives
man is primarily being reaching out for
meaning and this causes tension
indispensable tension not a tension next
state of inner equilibrium is what is
needed right so let's come back a minute
to your case of the older physician now
a lot of present-day psychotherapy would
concentrate on we do think kids in a day
in his angle and you're saying you just
reversed it and said the important thing
is to realize why use now that's a high
I did not say here's the pill that
didn't make you happy
there are also they exist also
psychological tranquilizer psychotherapy
he's at the right has been in
psychological tranquilizer instead of
reducing his pain I tried to make him
able to endure his painter and this is
one of those cycles and that's one of
the sharp differences in your approach
to psychotherapy and much of what we see
here in United I can't say there's one
of your basic point that modern that
auto look for the meaning of this so
decals easy
well I think you're doing very well how
its offensive and it's one of the ideas
that you were able to test out in your
own concentration camp and it was it was
because what was detecting the question
the problem which was protecting be
setting myself what not is much whether
or not I shall survive the camp but
whether or not all these things those
things people had to undergo innocent
people is trying to go there whether all
these dying around us has a meaning it
ultimately higher meaning or not for
each therefore it had no meaning
I didn't see any meaning even to survive
it I wonder if you understand where our
thought you're saying survival is not
enough nor even the basics of survival
for walk this is not the basic cladding
I arrived right along with this very
basic thought about not having the
tranquilizer but making sense out of
suffering in pain what are some of the
other basic ideas that you become a part
of your own approach I would say doctor
I would say that this teaching body of
local therapy is mainly based upon three
pillars three tenets pretty basic
assumption the first is the wheel -
meaning as opposed to a mere wheel -
pleasure pleasure principle according
psychoanalysis 4 3 2 power
aquatic odd oh right can I interrupt
that a minute please take this packet 1
now doesn't one need a backlog of some
interpretation to make an experience
meaningful for you - state of the old
man suffering yeah is a precious
responsibility of yours mr. Kent you had
something that made to give a
misinterpretation as suddenly but I
could evidence that even the scene for
my
average man on the street is primarily
for ultimately whatever term you would
prefer suction for me not in an
intellectual way of course in a more
implicit way simply his own personal
involvement yet experienced by by
committing to a cause higher than
himself by dedicating to a person whom
he loved
spiritual aspects and aspirations of man
are not primarily intellectual issues
right but primarily a matter of one's
personal conscience so your the
innermost contain a decision a matter of
love of dedication of commitment
this is human spirit but not intellect
or just rationalization I didn't mean
the right one was the world to me as
opposed to pleasure appease the meaning
of life which is conceived of within
this teaching body of logotherapy
in the following manner life never
ceases to have a meaning to hold the
meaning to meet any person and this is
you to that fact precisely to that fact
I was touching upon the world
the fact that even suffering may have a
meaning of course no suffering which is
take hold that in a masochistic way
let's say unnecessary but that's our
friend which is imposed upon our faith
by faith which is unavoidable by the
events of life that's right which may
not be related to the quality of one's
satisfied right and such necessary
unavoidable suffer in this case of it
depends every what matters and count is
how we have the discipline how we
approach this the attitude which we we
adopt in such ethical and finally the
Senate is after the way to meaning
the meaning of suffering then the
freedom of will you say this is a chain
of links of interconnected lis big an
example of the freedom of world an
example that I my contention is man is
never conditioned by conditions but he's
always free
he is never free from conditions but
what he is free it to take expand toward
the conditions confrontation in other
words when your parents were in a crisis
situation you couldn't control the
circumstance but you could elect today
or they know to kill Hitler by they had
a chance to do what was a father what
was a demanded of mine but let's adopt
apply more trivial example I am NOT
responsible that my hair is gray however
I'm responsible for the fact that I for
instance did not go to the hairdresser
having content my hair then though I
understand you're saying in part that
what's important is not only how you
feel which is where I think we so often
concentrate but what's also important is
what values you hold that then determine
the meaning of your feelings definitely
this is a very important factor this is
what I thought we don't yeah let me
quote a very fine sentence once uttered
by Carlos justice the boy in the central
cylinder who said what man is he
ultimately has become through because
which he has made his own but the main
gist of the adult is a tedious design
animal we cannot find our self our
identity except by devoting committing
ourselves to something for someone we
cannot struggle for self actualize
station except clue the foodie except to
the detour of devoting ourselves to the
cause to the world around the way the
way geysers around the world and not by
direct intention of our tenets
why that's a magnificent point we're
running out of time